I think,
you know,
during a downturn,
how much is advertising going to drop
by?
Well,
it may drop by,
you know,
three percent,
five percent.
It shouldn't be a total disaster for
anybody except those who are really on
the margin.
Uh,
at the same time I think we're still
though we're experiencing a very
longterm trend towards Internet based
advertising away from traditional media
and that is probably a big enough factor
that it would override for our industry.
Any downturn in general ad revenues,
uh,
I think that what we haven't seen in the
past,
but I think I agree with John Battelle,
who says that we sort of went down the
rat hole of a paper click advertising
for a long time and uh,
that the,
the idea of,
of brand advertising,
uh,
is one that,
that has not gotten,
has gotten its due,
um,
in,
in the online space.
I think it's because clicks are
measurable.
People over focused on clicks as a
measure of the effectiveness of the ad.
And so we haven't seen a lot of really,
really big advertisers doing all that
much online.
Uh,
but I think that'll change.
I mean,
just the idea that,
uh,
you know,
so pick your random big hepatitis or
like coca cola or Mcdonald's,
right?
Well,
they're not selling Coca Cola online
that it's not an ecommerce product and
never will be mcdonalds,
same thing.
Uh,
and so measuring the success of a,
of an advertisement online by click
through rate and the number of people
who came and played with your stupid
flash animation,
uh,
maybe not that great,
right?
I think instead they have to step back
and say,
oh,
actually,
this is kind of like TV,
right?
It's kind of like a billboard.
We put up a billboard,
we know how many people see it.
We really have,
um,
some historical understanding of what
that might mean for people thinking
about coke when they go to buy a
beverage next time.
Uh,
but we need a lot more of that on the
web just to say,
look,
actually we're gonna,
we're gonna Mention Koch's name in a
banner ad or in a little sidebar ad.
And we really don't care if people click
on it.
We really don't care.
It's not about that.
It's actually just getting that word in
front of people every day so that when
they do get ready to think about it,
that's one type of product.
Another type of product would be a very
information dense product.
So something like a Toyota Prius right
there.
I think that the lure of interactive
advertising is to actually,
um,
it is a bit ecommerce.
It is a bit get people to come and play
with your stupid flash site,
although hopefully it's not a stupid
flash site.
Hopefully,
uh,
you can say in that space,
look,
we actually feel like this is a product
that more people would want to buy a if
they understood it better,
right?
If we do research and we say,
well,
people kind of liked the idea of a
cleaner,
greener car with better gas mileage.
Uh,
but they're,
they heard it some kind of hybrid and
maybe they're a little scared of it and
they don't know,
you know,
does it run out of electricity or what
is that all about?
I don't know what the problems they face
are.
I'm just being hypothetical,
but it is a product where you can
imagine that lots of people would like
to go and learn more about it and then
actually maybe click and buy it,
you know.
So I think there's still like tons and
tons of room for a lot more ad money to
flow into this space away from
traditional models.
Uh,
and that'll,
that'll be a stronger effect than,
than anything.